welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Andrew Hill the J Clayton Stevenson
professor of anthropology and curator of
anthropology in the Peabody Museum at
Yale professor Hill is interested in the
whole range of human evolution
specifically in the environmental and
ecological context in which it occurred
since 1968 he has carried out fieldwork
in eastern Africa in Pakistan and in the
United Arab Emirates for many years he
has directed the Borrego paleontological
research project a multidisciplinary
research program operating in the two
ghen hills in Kenya this ongoing work
was the topic of a special double issue
of the journal of human evolution in
2002 and in 1999 he co-edited fossil
vertebrates of Arabia today we talk with
him about the climates influence on
human evolution welcome professor Hill
thank you very much you have done
extensive work in the Rift Valley in
Kenya as part of the Marengo research
project give us an overview of some of
your findings and what's come out of
there well let me start by just saying
why I'm doing that okay good because
basically what what I'm interested in is
the the changes that have taken place
since our divergence from our nearest
ancestors it's generally agreed now that
the chimpanzees are nearest living and
nearest living relative okay and that we
diverged from the line meeting to the
chimp about 7 million years ago and I'm
interested in the changes that took
place along our own lineage the one that
we refer to as homonyms and these are
among the things that make us uniquely
human things like bipedalism we walk on
our back Lakes which is a really odd
thing to do for animals other than birds
and the fact we have a really large
brain that's that's really strange and
that we have culture of various kinds
including material culture whether
they're you know hand axes or iPhones
this is gain is something very strange
and it's these are stages in our
evolution along that line and it's
generally held that such changes are
sort of encouraged or produced by
ecological shifts and changes in
environment that cause animals to become
adapted to different circumstances and
so basically what we're doing is looking
for that along that lineage and the
reason I work in Kenya in the Toobin
Hills is that there's a succession of
rocks there in the hills that goes back
to about 15 million years from now so
you cover the whole of human evolution
and Apes before them and there's fossils
all the way through and so it enables
you to find the fossils and also to find
indicators of climate and climate change
and so that's really what we're doing
that in the course of that we found some
interesting hominins we found what was
for 10 years the earliest and tell us
what is well hominin is the is the all
those creatures forming that branch
once we've diverged from chimpanzees so
it's those that are exclusively and at
what point in time did that happen that
probably happened around 7 million years
ago and the assumption is that it was
bipedality which characterized that
change
okay and we're let's get into that
because that's one of the one of your
findings is in terms of the environment
and when how many started walking on to
flirt so tell us about that well the the
idea given that it's such a strange
thing and it's always been used to sort
of define the group of animals we belong
to there's been a lot of interest about
that and there's a kind of story that
goes back a long way even almost to
Darwin that it was something to do with
a big change in environment in Africa
from the forests essentially a forest
environment that was all lush and dream
and lots of forests everywhere
to increasing aridity and the growth of
grasslands and the savannas come on the
scene and then I need to get some expect
legs and starts to wonder what to do
with its hands and it never struck me as
a very good theory because there was no
there was no real reason why savanna
should provoke this although it's it's a
nice myth and gradually we found that
that idea has been eroded over the past
decade or so and how did you find that
partly because in in the whole
succession we're where we would that
we're looking at there was no signs of
grassland and there are a number of ways
in which you can look for that and we
can talk about that in a second every
way yes but other things is that all the
all the very early hominids that have
been found now that now go back to
nearly seven million years are seem to
be associated with with woodland
environments and not these sort of sort
of ideal Serengeti migrants that most
people think Africa is my and so so the
evidence from from and you can do this
from that the reason you know they're
associated with woodlands is because the
animals are there you get things like
colobus monkeys that live in trees and
eat leaves and so on and various
antelopes that are very specific to
woodland conditions and and there are
various other ways of looking at it and
one way that we looked at it was to look
at carbon isotopes in soils in fossil
soils because it turns out that the
different carbon isotopes indicate
different kinds of vegetation and that
this is preserved into these little
modules that form in soils and it gives
you an idea of the sort of vegetation
that was growing at the time so you can
detect closed woodland sort of
vegetation and also grasslands and the
grasses that are in hot open conditions
have a different way of doing
photosynthesis and this is what you can
detect by looking at these isotopes and
what we found in doing this it was it
was mainly someone else who did this but
I was involved with it is that there is
no sign of these open grasslands that
you would otherwise
expect at any point all the way through
from 15 million years to now and it's
all a more mixed signal with woodlands
sometimes forests and so basically it
was Woodlands forests kind of an
environment when hominids came into
existence I think this is what we which
doesn't solve the problem of bipedal
let's talk about climate change in and
astronomical effects originally you
didn't think that astronomical effects
really had an effect on the Rift Valley
yeah a very interesting idea came came
in gradually it's been possible to
detect past climates but again by
various isotopic means and a lot of this
has been done through course through
deep-sea deep-sea caused from drilling
vessels and by looking at for example
oxygen isotopes you can get an idea of
sea temperature and this is clearly
something to do with climate it's also
been found to do with astronomical
variations and that they as the earth
moves around the Sun it Wiggles or in
various ways and there's a number these
are known as Milankovitch cycles that
people probably have heard of and that
there are these various Wiggles that
operate at various periodicity and they
they're basically fell if they're very
complex but the simple thing is that
they result in is different parts of the
earth facing nearest to the Sun at
different times in the past and this
affects how much sunlight is hitting the
earth in those places and this is what
seems to drive major climate change and
you can pick this up from things like
the oxygen isotope record and see that
this is actually happening
every and and and keep some people had
begun to say well this is what's driving
things in the Rift Valley where hominids
are living here and around there in
Africa the the problem with it was these
effects are less strong at the equator
for various reasons and the other thing
is that they they it has struck me that
the environment locally was so dominant
there's a very topographically diverse
area the Rift Valley with big cliffs and
and volcanoes
that is going to be local things that is
affecting weather rather than major
global things affecting things but I was
wrong as it turns out in fact one of the
amazing things I learned in in reviewing
your work is about the monsoons and how
you could actually tell how much rain
had fallen in any given period and how
these ginormous lakes form sort of a
surprise because as I said I had
convinced myself that what we were
observing there was essentially local
but we began to notice that they were
repeated things that known as data mites
they're very white rocks and they they
form in lakes and they they form from
the sort of little skeletons of
blue-green algae microscopic algae and
they die and they just sort of rain down
onto the bed of the lake and they're
very pure there's like 99% of these
things are these little silica remains
of these creatures or plants or whatever
blue-green algae are and they there's
very little input from outside and so
the very pure the beautiful is
stratified and we saw a succession of
these in the area we were working at
around 2 and 1/2 million years and we
had this thought what if this is
precession because this is one of these
little Milankovitch cycles that operates
at 23,000 year cycle and if these were
responding to changes in in the amount
of sun hitting the earth at that time
this is what you might expect and i a
lot of people have seen cycles like this
but without being able to show that they
really were to do with this astronomical
cycles and they can be due to all kinds
of things like changes in lake basins
and so on but we had someone who was
able to date these things incredibly
precisely and show that they occurred
every 23 thousand years which is exactly
the time period of precession and then
there are people not me but there are
people out there who understand these
cycles extremely well and you can
actually get on a webpage and find out
how much Sun is hitting the earth
anywhere at any time in the past and so
we were able to do this for the period
can
and and produce this little graph that
sum goes up and down and shows how the
the amount of some increases and then
gradually decreases and the dates for
these were exactly where we found the
Lakers right on the top of the very
abundant sunlight and it's quite clear
that that's what's driving this and then
so it's since then we've been able to go
further back into the past where you
also have these little packages of high
sunlight and also find evidence of lakes
it's a recurrent thing yes and I
wouldn't have thought we defined how has
the climate change affect evolution for
instance I remember reading that you
have these big lakes and then virtually
they would vanish relatively close that
must have some kind of yeah like I think
that the mean I I think it's wrong to
hope that there's sort of some simple
connection between sort of bipedalism
more making stone tools and lake
spearing I mean this is naive but the
the point that the the real thing that
impresses me about this is the fact that
we now know that these sort of climate
changes aren't local and these fill the
rift from side to side and that 60
kilometers across I mean they're huge
lakes and we can work that out as well
but it's not local and so even in places
where you don't have these obvious lakes
you're having similar climatic effects
you wouldn't expect the lakes everywhere
because you don't have situations for
Lake basins but there is an analogous
climatic effect operating there all over
Africa and they operate cyclically and
we know they go way into the past and
you can predict when they are and this
is happening everywhere and I think the
the thing that impresses me about it is
that we now know that Africa wasn't a
sort of constant environment for a long
long period of time with perhaps one
change and then another we know that
there's this sort of pulsing and and
that's normally what's thought others
driving evolution is changed that breaks
up vegetation and basic environment
animals and is that kind of what you're
getting at when you use the word
kaleidoscope yeah I don't whether that's
effective but you mean it struck me it
was like every now and again quite
suddenly and quite often really every
years of - you're sort of shaking up the
whole environment like as if it was in a
kaleidoscope things are dispersing and
getting isolated in small pockets here
or having to go somewhere else and then
quite quickly they come together again
but it's a slightly different pattern
and that's the sort of structure that
you need for just Darwinian natural
selection to operate and you've been
able to find actual evidence of that
happening well we what we're doing now
is looking at the animals because we
have a good a good evidence of
foreigners all the way through and we're
monitoring faunal change as you go
through these climatic shifts and we we
don't have any direct hard evidence yet
but we're getting there with our next
thing if you could go back travel back
in time to the time of the hominids what
would you most hope to be able to see
that would be nice I don't I don't think
it's one thing because that the thing
that's sort of irritating about about
the subject is that it is a science and
I would defend that in front of any
white lab coat to the person but it is a
science but it's it's about the past
things that nearly everything you're
looking at has already happened and a
long time ago
and there's no real reason why we should
expect to know anything about what we
were like in the deep past but we happen
to because of a few rare fossils and but
what it means is that the the obvious
questions people would ask you can't
answer you know how many what did this
look like was it furry this ancestor did
it have red and blue patches on its face
what was the group size was it five or
fifty you know you don't you don't know
these what is it eating whereas an
ecologist can go and watch a panda and
see it put bamboo in its mouth you know
and I think that if you could get back
there it wouldn't be you wouldn't be
looking for one thing you'd just be
impressed by everything you should be
like going into a game part to remote in
time where you could see everything
happening and you'd have so much more
information if you could do that maybe
you can get me a time yes I wish I
thank you so much for being here with us
and sharing some of your work it's been
fascinating thank you very much for more
information about professor Hill and his
research please visit our website at
Yale edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale